washington abruptly released running
back darius geiss on friday a second
round pick in 2018 who has only appeared
in five games due to injury cut after
being arrested on multiple counts
related to domestic violence including a
felony count of strangulation
he was according to his lawyer cut
without any effort by the team to talk
to him to get an explanation limited
investigation if any by the authorities
before the charges were filed it doesn't
stun me that washington would move so
swiftly given the other issues that the
organization has been dealing with these
are serious charges but again he's
entitled to a defense somewhere somehow
it won't matter for him in washington he
went unclaimed on waivers yesterday
chris he's now a free agent and he
likely won't be signed by anyone because
if he signed he'd be put on the
commissioner exempt list most likely and
be paid to not play so he's going to
have to get this legal issue worked out
before he continue his career let's
focus on it from the standpoint of
washington without him in the forward
and again he's only played in five games
over the last two seasons tournament acl
rookie year in the preseason against the
patriots five games last year injuries
kept him from fully blossoming what does
it mean to that backfield to have him
not there well he he has a chance to be
the go he had a chance to be the go-to
guy the bell cow runner i mean their guy
he's a guy that came out of lsu you know
how to kind of sit in the
coattails of leonard fournette and when
he got his chance to play
you know there was high hopes for this
kid
and certainly you know i know that when
he came out of lsu a few years ago there
was teams that viewed him as a first
round pick i think the washington
football team even said that that they
thought he was a first-round type talent
so you know this is a big blow to their
football team and they don't really have
anything on their team as far as proven
commodity at running back other than
adrian peterson you know they got some
journeyman and a guy like jd mckissick
peyton barber yes good player solid you
know i don't know it might be going down
on a little bit of a of a downhill track
here as far as you know his career is
concerned can they get something from
bryce love remember him from stanford
mike few years ago i mean he was in the
heisman conversation i know he's had
some leg issues and some other injuries
that have bothered him but if he can get
back to his college form maybe he can be
the guy and then the intriguing guy on
the bottom there antonio gibson he's a
guy i like coming out in the draft mike
you know another one of these
weapons where i'm not sure if you want
to call him a wide receiver a running
back you know he's like a debo samuel
for the 49ers you can put him a tailback
and give him reverses and sweeps but he
can catch slants over the middle and run
away from people too maybe he gets in
the fold there but either way
it certainly hurts them a little bit at
that position and and we know they have
wide receiver issues they need to rely
on their running game this year
even though the sample size was small
for darius geiss with five games yeah he
had
42 carries 245 yards that's an average
of 5.8 yards per attempt that's pretty
damn good now again we're not talking
about an extensive and full season type
you know if it's 5 8 for the full season
and you played 16 games then you're jim
brown but uh
it is going to be a loss from the
standpoint of they kept waiting and
waiting for geist to break out and they
thought the injury issues were finally
behind him
almost two years removed from the torn
acl
and the supplement with adrian peterson
and i you know i was surprised adrian
peterson did a multi-year deal to stay
with that team because
with geist there he's not going to get
anything close to what he wants chris i
think this sets up
unless bryce love
is healthy and can be as effective as he
was at stanford before his own torn acl
this sets up for adrian peterson once
again
getting the kind of carries the kind of
touches the kind of opportunities to be
that battering ram between the tackles
that he's been for all these years if he
can stay healthy given his advancing age
it's it's amazing to see it all set up
for him to potentially have another
thousand yard season
in washington but he could have another
thousand yard season yeah well
definitely i mean come on he's one of
the freakiest guys we've ever seen i
think at this the very least it sets up
that early in the season
you know i think you'll see them rely on
adrian peterson until you know maybe
some of these younger guys the bryce
loves the antonio gibsons can get in the
trust tree to where okay hey ooh we can
give this guy the ball 20 times a game
and he'll take care of it so i that
that's the thing that that means to me
more than anything guys yeah had a
chance to be you know a talented running
back but
you know again from day one there's been
little there was little issues with
darius guys too whether it was the weird
combine story
and there was a lot of other stories out
there as well
to where
yeah it just seems like washington
didn't want to deal with it and you're
right it's setting up for adrian
peterson to get one more chance at it
and i would think him and peyton barber
carry the the you know share the load
here early on until one of those young
guys you know is is trustworthy
they basically pulled adrian peterson
off the couch in august of 2018. he
started all 16 games that year and had
1042 yards rushing in washington last
year 898
yards rushing still averaging over four
yards per carry even after all these
years in the nfl and i think he becomes
the guy like you said out of the gates
and and can he stay healthy that really
is the key as a running back gets older
and older you can't expect him to
continue to take that pounding and he's
had injury issues in the past he had the
torn acl at the end of the 2011 season
he had a knee injury in 2016 that
knocked him out it was a torn meniscus
most of the year he missed his last year
in minnesota but if he can stay healthy
he could be great and he
he still aspires chris to catch emmett
smith he only needs
4139 yards to get there yeah and frank
gore's got a better chance of catching
emma smith at this point than adrian
peterson but one thing i learned early
on in adrian peterson's career never bet
against this guy and and the planets are
lining up for him yet again to have a
chance to have a big year it's now all
up to him well you know he's gonna be
ready to go i mean he's a psycho he
loves training loves football and he is
motivated still i can certainly see him
getting the number four i don't think
number one is happening but it still he
amazes us every year we keep thinking oh
this will probably be it and then we're
sitting in the control room on a sunday
going man look at adrian peterson are
you kidding me
um but but nonetheless it stinks for the
washington football team who you know
had potential to build a young nucleus
here with haskins and terry mclaren and
maybe a darius geiss and that's gone and
that's just unfortunate and it's
unfortunate for their team in general
because
they lack guys that can make big time
plays on the offensive side of the ball
as good as adrian peterson might still
be he's not going to be ripping off 50
60 yard touchdown runs they don't have
that big cly other a big big play guy
other than terry mclaurin and guys
probably would have been second on that
list and now he's gone they're gonna
have to go somewhere else
amazing to think that in the year 2020
the starting quarterback for the
washington football team could be alex
smith the starting tailback could be
adrian peterson when they get rolling
five weeks from yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports